مساء المحبّة،
اليوم،الرابع عشر من شهر فبراير/شباط،
يحتفل العالم بعيد الحب،
الذي اختلفت الروايات حول أصوله،
البعض يذهب إلى أنه عيد وثني روماني،
تبنته الكنيسة المسيحية كما تبنت العديد من الأعياد الرومانية الأخرى.
والبعض الآخر يعتبر ان هذا العيد مرتبط بقصة كاهنٌ،
اسمه فالنتين،
عاش في فترة حكم الإمبراطور الروماني كلوديوس،
الذي عُرف باضطهاده للمسحيين.
هذا الكاهن فالنتين تحدّى قرارا للإمبراطور كلوديوس،
يقضي بمنع زواج الشّباب، لحاجته إليهم في الحروب،
فالجُنود غير المتزوجّين في تقديره،
أفضلُ وأكثر كفاءةً في أداء عملهم من الجنودِ المُتزوّجين.
الكاهن فالنتاين سيقوم بتزويج  بعض الجنود المسيحيين سرا،
وعندما أُكتشف أمره أُلقِي عليه القبضُ ووُضِعَ في السّجن وعُذِّب،
وأُعدم في الرابع عشر  من شهر فبراير/ شباط سنة 269 ميلادية.
البابا في روما وقتئذ، جيلاسيوس الأول،
هو الذي وضع الرزنامة الرسمية لأعياد القدّيسين
في الكنيسة المسيحية سنة 496 ميلادي،
ومنها عيد القديس فالنتين.
وجيلاسيوس الأول هذا،
ينحدر من شمال إفريقيا،
من وسط تونس حاليا،
وبالتحديد من قبيلة امازيغية تسمّى قبيلة "جلاص"،
ولقب الجلاصي من أشهر الألقاب المنتشرة في تونس اليوم.
ونحن نحتفل هذا المساء بعيد الحب،
سوف أحدثكم عن علاقة ثالوث يمثل جوهر الاجتماع البشري،
وهو ثالوث الزواج والحب والدين.
منذ ظهور الاجتماع البشري،
عملت المؤسسة الدينية على الهيمنة على مؤسسة الزواج،
وحصر دورها في المحافظة على النوع البشري،
وحرصت على جعل المرأة
الطرف الأضعف داخل هذه المؤسسة،
دورها الرئيسي هو الإمتاع الجنسي والتناسل.
بُنيت مؤسسة الزواج عبر مختلف الثقافات،
حول رموز متعددة،
من أهمها عقد الزواج،
ويعود أول عقد زواج بين رجل وامرأة
إلى حوالي أربعة ألاف عام في بلاد ما بين النهرين.
الخاتم كذلك، هو احد طقوس الزواج،
حيث جعل الرومان خاتم الخطوبة كرمز للإرتباط الأبدي،
وكانوا يعتقدون بوجود شريان
يمتد من إصبع البنصر في اليد اليسرى،
اين يوضع الخاتم إلى القلب مباشرة.
العذرية كذلك، طقس من الطقوس العابرة للتاريخ وللثقافات.
المهر أيضا،
هو أحد الأسس الرئيسية في مؤسسة الزواج عبر التاريخ.
الديانات التوحيدية الثلاث؛
اليهودية والمسيحية والإسلام
أولت أهمية كبرى لمؤسسة الزواج،
باعتبارها المنتجة للنواة الأولى للمجتمع وهي الأسرة.
سوف يجعل الدين لمؤسسة الزواج دورا رئيسيا،
في مراقبة الهوية ورسم الحدود أمام الآخر العقائدي والثقافي.
فحرّمت الديانة اليهودية الزواج المختلط،
حفاظا على نقاء العرق اليهودي.
وستحرّم الديانة المسيحية مع بولس الرسول الزواج بغير المسيحي،
وستلغي مبدأ الطلاق وتقرّ الزواج مدى الحياة،
وابتداء من سنة 1215 ميلادية،
سوف يتحول الزواج إلى سرّ مقدّس من أسرار الكنيسة السبعة،
وهي؛ سرّ المعمودية، وسرّ المَيْرون، وسرّ القربان المقدّس،
و سرّ التوبة، و سرّ الإعتراف، و سرّ مسحة المرضى، و سرّ الزواج، وسرّ الكهنوت.
إذن أصبح الزواج يُعقد في الكنيسة وبرعاية القس،
ولابد من إشهاره في الكنيسة قبل الحفل.
في الإسلام توافقت أحكام الزواج،
مع أعراف الزواج الشائعة في الجزيرة العربية عموما،
وفي قبيلة قريش خصوصا، قبل ظهور الإسلام.
وجرى تحريم بعض أشكال الزواج السابقة له،
التي لم تكن شائعة على نطاق واسع،
مثل زواج الشغار، وزواج البدل، وزواج الاستبضاع، وزواج الرهط.
استقى الإسلام سلطة الولي في عقد الزواج من العرف الجاهلي،
واخذ منه المهر كركن أساسي من أركان الزواج،
واستمد منه المحرّمات من النساء،
وأضاف لها تحريم الزواج بامرأة الاب والجمع بين الأختين.
واقتبس كذلك تعدد الزوجات ونظام الطلاق من أعراف الجاهلية.
وحرّم الزواج من كفّار قريش،
وأحلّه من أهل الكتاب، اليهود والنصارى.
الديانات الثلاث،
التي جعلت من مؤسسة الزواج هدفها المحافظة على الجنس البشري،
و الإمتاع الجنسي خاصة للرجل،
وضمان توريث الثروة للأبناء،
وعقد تحالفات عسكرية وسياسية بين القبائل والأمراء والملوك،
سوف تكون في تحد أمام مارد الحبّ.
فالحب لم يكن ركنا أساسيا من أركان الزواج
في العصر القديم والوسيط، بل كان منبوذا.
وابتداء من ظهور البرجوازية في أوروبا الغربية،
كطبقة حاملة لمشروع قيمي جديد،
سيتحول الحب إلى حجر زاوية لمؤسسة الزواج.
وسيظهر مع الثورة الفرنسية الزواج المدني،
الذي سيحرر هذه المؤسسة من سلطة الكنيسة،
وسيعود مع الحب نظام الطلاق من جديد إلى أوروبا المسيحية.
إذن زواج الحب،
سيعوّض تدريجيا الزواج التقليدي القائم على المصلحة،
وسيتجاوز سلطة رجل الدين،
ويكون من أهم نتائجه الزواج المختلط،
الذي سيعيد ترسيم الحدود بين الأعراق والثقافات والأديان.
رغم هذه الثورة القيمية والتشريعية
التي وقعت منذ قرون في كافة أنحاء العالم،
ظلت مؤسسة الزواج في عالمنا العربي والإسلامي،
سجينة تراث فقهي قروسطي لا يتلاءم مع روح العصر.
فكلّ الدول العربية ترفض الزواج المدني المختلط،
بإستثناء تونس.
تونس،
التي ألغت في الرابع عشر من شهر سبتمبر/أيلول سنة 2017،
جميع القوانين المانعة لزواج التونسية بالأجنبي غير المسلم.
وكان القانون التونسي، وفق منشور يعود إلى سنة 1973،
ينص على أن "الاعتراف بزواج تونسية مسلمة برجل غير مسلم،
يتطلب تقديم شهادة تثبت اعتناق الرجل للإسلام".
هذه الخطوة الجريئة، والتي كانت بإرادة سياسية،
من الرئيس التونسي الراحل الباجي قائد السبسي رحمه الله،
أثارت جدلا كبيرا في العالم العربي والإسلامي،
وجعلت الرئيس التونسي الباجي قائد السبسي،
في مرمى فتاوى التكفير والخروج عن الملة،
من مؤسسات دينية قروسطية وعلى رأسها مؤسسة الأزهر في مصر.
طبعا الأمر غير مستغرب من مؤسسة دينية مثل الأزهر،
كانت ولازالت الحارس لمعبد التراث الإسلامي بغثّه وسمينه،
وتصدّت بشدّة لكلّ أصوات التجديد الديني من داخلها أو من خارجها،
وكان ولازال التكفير والإخراج من الملّة،
بتهمة إنكار معلوم من الدين بالضرورة من أكثر أسلحتها نجاعة.
لكن،
بعد ثلاث سنوات من الخطوة التونسية الجريئة،
بدأ البناء الوثوقي والدغمائي للأزهر في التصدّع من الداخل،
حيث ذكرت مؤخرا الدكتورة آمنة نُصير،
أستاذة الفلسفة والعقيدة في جامعة الأزهر،
أنه لا يوجد نص قرآني صريح يحرم زواج المسلمة من الكتابي،
اي المسيحي أو اليهودي.
استمعوا إلى ما صرحت به الدكتورة آمنة نُصيرفي هذا الشأن؛
هناك تصريح ثاني، يقول انه لا وجود لنص يحرّم زواج المسلمة من غير المسلم،
هل لك أن تشرحي لنا...
انظري، غير المسلم، المسيحي واليهودي،
وهم أهل كتاب،
أهل كتاب،
والقرآن سماهم هكذا،
أهل الكتاب،
يعني أنهم ليسوا بعبدة أصنام،
وغير منكرين لله سبحانه وتعالى،
ولكن لهم ديانة أخرى تختلف عنّا،
في مثل هذه الحالة،
إذا طبّق ما يطبّقه المسلم، عندما يتجوز بالمسيحية أو اليهودية،
لأنه لا يكرهها على تغيير دينها،
ولا يمنعها من مسجدها،
ولا يحرمها من قرآنها،
ولا يحرمها من أداء صلاتها...
تصريح آمنة نُصير أثار ضجة كبيرة،
وردت دار الإفتاء المصرية بالنص الآتي؛
«لا يجوز للمسلمة أن تتزوج من غير المسلم وهذا الحكم الشرعي (قطعي)،
ويشكل جزءًا من هوية الإسلام والعلة الأساس في هذه المسألة تعبدية؛
بمعنى عدم معقولية المعنى،
فإن تجلّى بعد ذلك شيءٌ من أسباب هذا التحريم فهي حِكَمٌ لا عِلَل.
فالأصل في الزواج أنه أمرٌ لاهوتيٌّ وسرٌّ مقدس،
وصفه ربنا تبارك وتعالى بالميثاق الغليظ؛
فقال تعالى: ﴿وَأَخَذْنَ مِنْكُمْ مِيثَاقًا غَلِيظًا﴾ [النساء: 21]».
الردّ لم يأت فقط من المؤسسات الدينية الإسلامية،
كذلك الأقباط عبّروا عن رفضهم لهذه الفكرة،
حيث أصدرت حركة " شباب كريستيان للأقباط الأرثوذكس" بياناً مفاده:
" من تزوجت من غير مسيحي، أو من تزوج من غير مسيحية،
فهو زان ويحرم كنسياً،
هذا هو قانون كنيستنا القبطية الارثوذكسية ودستورنا ومرجعنا الوحيد هو الكتاب المقدس".
المؤسسات الدينية الإسلامية والمؤسسات الدينية القبطية،
متفقة على رفض الزواج المختلط بين المسلمين والمسيحيين،
وهذا الأمر ليس بجديد،
استمعوا إلى رد البابا شنودة على فتاة مسيحية،
ترغب في الزواج من شاب غير مسيحي .
واحدة تقول، انا أحب فتى غير مسيحي، مع العلم انني مرتبطة بالكنيسة وبالرب، ماذا أفعل؟
حقلّك شوية أسئلة، حقلّك شوية أسئلة تحطيها في مخّك، باستمرار وتفكري فيها،
العلاقة دي ستنتهي على إيه؟
ده أول سؤال،
فإن كانت لا تنتهي إلى ارتباط، يبقى أنت بتتعبي  نفسك عاطفيا، وموش حترتبطي بيه.
النقطة الثانية،
إذا حدث ارتباط،
فهل سيكون زواج مسيحي والا زواج غير مسيحي؟
وان كان زواج غير مسيحي، سوف تنفصلين كل المجتمع المسيحي الذي تعيشين فيه
وعن أسترتك وأصحابك وهن الكنيسة وعن كل حتّة،
باردو خلّي بالك من هذه النقطة،
وإذا ارتبطي بزواج غير مسيحي،
سوف تحكمين على كل اخواتك البنات واخواتك الأولاد إنهم لا يتزوجون،
بسببك.
وإذا ارتبطي بزواج غير مسيحي،
فهل العيال إلّي حتخلّفيهم سيكونون مسيحيين أو غير مسيحيين،
طبعا سيكونون غير مسيحيين،
شوفي يا بنتي اعقلي واثقلي،
ولا ترتبطي عاطفيا بعاطفة لا يمكن أن تؤدي إلى نتيجة أو تؤدي إلى نتيجة فيها ضياع لك،
كذلك في الزواج فيه مثل لطيف يقول،
من شروط المرافقة الموافقة،
فالزواج عبارة عن اثنين ماشين مع بعض لازم يكونو متفقين في كل شيء،
مثل حصانين يجران عربة،
يقفان في وقت واحد ويمشيان في وقت واحد،
وإن مشيا يمشيان بسرعة واحدة وفي اتجاه واحد، لو اختلفا، العربة لن تمر،
الواحد يقاوم الموضوع من أوله قبل أن يتطور والحكاية اتلخبط...
ويعني ما فيه غير الولد ده، ما فيه أولاد كثير ماليين الدنيا...
"يعني ما فيه غير الولد ده، ما فيه أولاد كثير ماليين الدنيا..."
يا قداسة البابا، سلام على روحك،
هيّ لا يعنيها في شيء أمر كل شبّان العالم،
هذه الفتاة تحب فقط هذا الشاب الذي أنت حرمتها منه.
كل رجل دين، عندما يتحدث عن دينه يقول ان دينه دين محبّة،
إذا كان الأمر كذلك،
كيف اتفق كل رجال الدين من كل الديانات على التفريق بين المحبّين؟
نعود لأسس موقف الفقه الإسلامي من قضية زواج المسلمة بالكتابي.
أولا،
لا يوجد نص قرآني يحرّم زواج المسلمة بالكتابي،
وكل الفقهاء متفقون على ان التحريم،
جاء بناء على إجماع جمهور علماء الإسلام وليس استنادا إلى نص قرآني.
الفقيه الإسلامي عندما يريد تحريم زواج المسلمة بالكتابي،
سوف يستشهد بالآية 221 من سورة البقرة، التي تقول؛
"وَلَا تَنكِحُوا الْمُشْرِكَاتِ حَتَّىٰ يُؤْمِنَّ ۚ وَلَأَمَةٌ مُّؤْمِنَةٌ خَيْرٌ مِّن مُّشْرِكَةٍ وَلَوْ أَعْجَبَتْكُمْ ۗ
وَلَا تُنكِحُوا الْمُشْرِكِينَ حَتَّىٰ يُؤْمِنُوا ۚ وَلَعَبْدٌ مُّؤْمِنٌ خَيْرٌ مِّن مُّشْرِكٍ وَلَوْ أَعْجَبَكُمْ".
ولكن،
عندما يريد نفس هذا الفقيه أن يشرّع الزواج من الكتابية الشقراء ذات العينين الزرقاوين،
سوف يستشهد لك بالآية الخامسة من سورة المائدة  التي تقول:
" الْيَوْمَ أُحِلَّ لَكُمُ الطَّيِّبَاتُ ۖ وَطَعَامُ الَّذِينَ أُوتُوا الْكِتَابَ حِلٌّ لَّكُمْ وَطَعَامُكُمْ حِلٌّ لَّهُمْ ۖ
وَالْمُحْصَنَاتُ مِنَ الْمُؤْمِنَاتِ وَالْمُحْصَنَاتُ مِنَ الَّذِينَ أُوتُوا الْكِتَابَ مِن قَبْلِكُمْ."
الفقيه يتعمّد الخلط بين ثلاثة مفاهيم مختلفة في النص القرآنى وهي،
المشركين والكفّار وأهل الكتاب.
عندما يريد أن يُحلّ شيئا من أهل الكتاب مثل الزواج من نسائهم يسميهم أهل كتاب،
وعندما يريد أن يحرّم شيئا عليهم يسمّيهم كفارا أو مشركين...
الآية 221 من سورة البقرة التي تحرّم الزواج من المشركين،
هي آية عامة وتنطبق على الرجال والنساء من المسلمين.
فإذا حرّمت زواج الكتابي من المسلمة استنادا لهذه الآية لأنه كافر،
عليك كذلك ان تحرّم زواج المسلم بالكتابيّة لأنها كافرة كذلك استنادا لنفس الآية.
والآية الخامسة من سورة المائدة،
التي تُحلّ زواج المسلم من الكتابية لا تحرّم زواج المسلمة من الكتابي.
من الأسباب التي يذكرها الفقهاء،
لتبرير تحريم زواج المسلمة بالكتابي وشرعية زواج المسلم بالكتابية؛
هو ان المسلم سوف يحترم معتقد الكتابية،
لأنه يؤمن بنبوة أنبياء بني إسرائيل ونبوة المسيح عيسى بن مريم،
في حين ان المسيحي أو اليهودي لا يؤمن بنبوة محمّد.
إذا كان الأمر كذلك،
لماذا يرفض المسلمون تزويج بناتهم للدروز،
وهم فرقة مسلمة موحّدة وتؤمن بكل الأنبياء الذين يؤمن بهم المسلمين؟
ولماذا يرفض المسلمون تزويج بناتهم للبهائيين،
وهي ديانة موحّدة منشقة عن الإسلام تؤمن بنبوة محمد وكل الأنبياء الذين سبقوه؟
اما القول،
ان الفقه الإسلامي قد ضمن حقوق الكتابية عند زواجها بالمسلم فهذا غير صحيح،
لأن المذاهب الفقهية الاربعة،
قد حرمت الزوجة الكتابية من ميراث زوجها المسلم أو أبنائها  بعد الوفاة،
استنادا إلى حديث نبوي يقول:
"لا يرث المسلم الكافر، ولا الكافر المسلم".
لاحظوا هنا مرّة أخرى،
الفقيه عندما أراد حرمان الزوجة الكتابية من ميراث زوجها نعتها بالكفر،
مثلما نعت الكتابي بالكفر لتحريم زواجه من المسلمة.
لو عدنا للآيات القرآنية المتعلقة بموضوع الإرث،
نجد بأن الإرث غير مرتبط اطلاقا بموضوع الدين وعقيدة الوارث،
وإنما يقوم على رابطة القربى ورابطة الدم والرحم،
ولتقفوا على مدى سوء نية الفقيه الإسلامي في هذه القضية،
أحيلكم على فتوى أصدرها مجلس الافتاء الأوروبي،
الذي أسسه يوسف القرضاوي،
والتي تبيح أن يرث المسلم من غير المسلم وليس العكس،
كي يسمح للمسلمين بأن يرثوا زوجاتهم الأوروبيات،
مُعللا فتواه بنص الحديث القائل:
" الاسلام يَزيد ولا ينقُص"،
اي ان المسلم لأنه فقط مسلم لابأس أن يزيد ماله من غير المسلم!
الفقيه الإسلامي يقدّم  قراءة تمييزية استعلائية للنص القرآني،
تتناقض مع جوهره الأخلاقي باعتباره خطابا كونيا موجّه للناس أجمعين.
في ما يتعلّق بقضية حسن معاملة المسلم للمرأة المسلمة،
رجاء،
كيف لعاقل ان يصدّق،
ان الرجل المسلم الذي يعيش في بلدان،
لا تحترم حقوق الإنسان عموما وحقوق المرأة خصوصا،
ان يعامل المرأة المسلمة احسن من الأوروبي،
الذي يعيش في بلدان بينها وبين البلدان العربية والإسلامية سنين ضوئية،
في مجال حقوق المرأة والقوانين والتشريعات الحامية لها؟
لماذا لا نريد أن نعترف،
بأن قضية رفض الزواج المختلط في مجتمعاتنا ثقافية بالأساس؛
المسلم المغاربي، الجزائري أو المغربي أو التونسي أو الموريتاني هنا في فرنسا،
والذي يُصلّي كل يوم جمعة في المسجد مع الشاب المسلم المالي أو السينغالي،
لا يرغب في أن يُزوّجه ابنته.
والمسلم الخليجي، السعودي أو القطري او الإماراتي او الكويتي،
الذي يصلي كل يوم جمعة في نفس المسجد، مع الشاب المسلم البنغالي او الباكستاني او السوداني او المصري،
لن يقبل ان يزوجه ابنته.
ورغم كل هذا الإنغلاق،
ورفض الآخر،
توجد آلاف الزيجات المختلطة الناجحة بين مسلمات وغير مسلمين،
سواء في الغرب أو في العالم العربي،
وإليكم هذه اللقطات الجميلة من حفل زفاف في لبنان،
بين الشابة المسلمة سيرينا مملوك ورجل الأعمال المسيحي أنطوني قاعور.
زواج جميل أقوى من الطائفة،
يثبت ان الحب لا دين ولا لون ولا عرق له...
في تراثنا الإسلامي توجد قصّة حب رائعة كنت قد كتبت حولها في السابق،
وهي قصة زينب بنت الرسول،
وهي أكبر بناته من زوجته خديجة بنت خويلد،
لم تحدثنا عنها كتب السيرة والتراث كثيرا مثل شقيقاتها رقيّة وأم كلثوم وفاطمة.
أهمّ من ذكرها “البلاذري” في كتابه، أنساب الأشراف،
وذكرها “ابن سعد” في كتابه، الطبقات الكبرى.
تزوّجت زينب بعد قصّة حب جميلة،
من أبي العاص بن الربيع وهو إبن خالتها هالة بنت خويلد.
كانت زينب وشقيقاتها وأمّها خديجة،
من الأوائل اللواتي إعتنقن الإسلام وآمنّ بنبوّة محمّد،
وهو ما جلب عليهنّ سخط قريش،
بعد إحتدام الصراع بين النبي وعمّه عبد العزّى،
المعروف بكنية ابي لهب وزوجته أم جميل،
المعروفة بكنية حمّالة الحطب في النصّ القرآني،
وبالتحديد في سورة المسد التي نزلت في ذمّهما،
وهو ما دفع إبنيهما عتبة وعتيبة إلى تطليق زوجتيهما
بنتي النبي محمّد أم كلثوم ورقيّة،
في حين رفض أبو العاص بن الربيع زوج زينب تطليقها،
رغم انّه لم يعتنق الإسلام ورفض التخلّي عن دين أبائه وأجداده،
وكان يقول:
«لا والله، إنِّي لا أفارق صاحبتي، وما أُحِبُّ أنَّ لي بامرأتي امرأة من قريش» .
زينب ردّت على نبل زوجها أبي العاص وحبّه لها بحبّ أكبر،
عندما رفضت الهجرة إلى المدينة مع والدها وشقيقاتها،
وآثرت البقاء مع زوجها في مكّة.
شارك أبو العاص ابن الربيع في غزوة بدر،
ووقع أسيرا عند جيش المسلمين مع سبعين رجلا من قريش.
وبعد ان وضعت المعركة أوزارها،
بعث أهل مكّة المال لإفتداء أبنائهم الأسرى عند المسلمين،
وبعثت زينب بدورها المال وقلادة كانت اهدتها لها أمّها خديجة عند زواجها لإفتداء زوجها الأسير عند والدها،
تاثّر النبي محمّد تأثّرا شديدا عندما رأى القلادة،
وفوّض امر أبي العاص لصحابته الذين قرّروا إطلاق سراحه وإرجاع مال زينب وقلادتها،
في المقابل تعهّد بأن يبعث بزينب إلى المدينة حال وصوله إلى مكّة.
أوفى أبو العاص بعهده وبعث بزوجته زينب إلى والدها رفقة شقيقه كنانة بن الربيع،
ولكن إعترض سبيلها فارسان من قريش أسقطاها من هودجها،
وتقول الروايات انها كانت حاملا وفقدت حملها.
بعد ذلك تمكّن زوجها من إخراجها ليلا من مكّة وتأمين وصولها إلى المدينة،
وظلّت طيلة سنوات إقامتها هناك متعلّقة بزوجها،
ورفضت رفضا قاطعا كلّ عروض الزواج من المسلمين مهاجرين وأنصارا .
في السنة الثامنة للهجرة وقعت قافلة أبي العاص بن الربيع وهو عائد من الشام،
في كمين نصبته له إحدى سرايا المسلمين فأغارت عليه ونهبت أمواله،
وتمكّن هوّ من الفرار ودخل المدينة ليلا وطرق باب زوجته زينب مستجيرا،
أدخلته بيتها، وذهبت إلى المسجد حيث كان النبي يؤمّ المصلّين وصرخت:
“أيها الناس، أنا زينب بنت محمد، وقد أجرت أبا العاص فأجيروه.
فلما سلّم النبي بعد الصلاة، التفت إلى الناس وقال :
هل سمعتم ما سمعت،
قالوا: نعم يا رسول الله،
قال :
"والذي نفسي بيده ما علمت بشيء من ذلك حتى سمعت ما سمعتموه، وإنه يُجير من المسلمين أدناهم".
وكانت الإستجارة قيمة ثابتة عند العرب قبل الإسلام وبعده،
فأمر النبي ان يُعاد له ماله وان يؤمّن له الطريق ليعود سالما إلى مكّة،
وقال فيه ؛ حدثني فصدقني، ووعدني فوفى لي.
أجمعت كل كتب السيرة على انّه اعلن إسلامه فيما بعد وعاش مع زينب إلى أن وافتها المنيّة.
زينب دافعت عن حبّها أكثر من عقدين من الزمن،
وتحدّت أعراف القبيلة ونواميس السماء ولم تستمع إلاّ إلى نبضات قلبها.
فالنتاين مات من اجل الحبّ، وزينب عاشت من أجل الحبّ ...
وكلاهما قدّيس للحبّ،
فكنّ مثل زينب ولا تستمعن سوى لنبض قلوبِكُنّ.
أشكركم على المتابعة، وكل عيد حب وانتم بالف خير،
لا تنسوا الإشتراك في القناة وتفعيل الجرس ليصلكم كل جديد...
دمتم بخير وإلى لقاء قريب.